there's a picture of joe biden that's
been getting some attention it's been
all over twitter
take a look all right well the thing
people were talking about
obviously is that the hat biden's
wearing says we just did
and it's obviously a clever response to
the famous trump slogan make america
great again yeah
it looks like biden's hat also caught
the attention of those on the trump team
because then donald trump jr posted a
photo of himself wearing this hat
but we did it first so suck it
not a very classy response which is
probably why kamal harris posted a
picture
wearing this hat why don't you say that
to my face donnie
which then got this response from
melania trump only faces yours to suck
give to me a break yeah so it's getting
pretty heated
aoc responded to that picture on
instagram melania i'm not entirely sure
what you're trying to say but i think
it's an insult either way
by felicia then eric trump posted this
picture
who farted not really sure
where he's going there then rudy
giuliani jumped in with a picture of him
wearing this hat
you corrupt democrats won't be so smug
when i unveil my bombshell evidence of
massive voter fraud 30 million illegal
votes
and finally president obama responded
with this picture
there's of course giuliani in borat 2.